are you gonna um because i feel like
what i love
recently i don't know if you've noticed
cardi b's been suing blogs that have
been posting fake [ __ ] about her
and she sued some lady and got like a
suitor for three million dollars pretty
much bankrupted his blog
but i feel like loki the way to combat
that kind of behavior is to make sure
that those people who
accuse you of some [ __ ] or whatever
[ __ ] about you like sue the [ __ ] out of
them they posted the [ __ ] i don't even
mean the blogs i mean like the lady who
who accuses you can't you sue her for
sure like the information the character
i don't give a [ __ ] you ain't got number
glass of water i want that cup give me
the cup of water yeah yeah a cup of
water i want your new balances i want
your [ __ ] holy [ __ ] what you
you got a [ __ ] uh
you gotta wait ultimate give me the old
weight ultimate on this [ __ ] yeah
give me seventy-five percent of the only
fans yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] they're bombing
[ __ ] nah man being them [ __ ] don't even
get [ __ ]
in trouble for the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
just get to go about their lives and go
try to do it to another [ __ ] and
john doe the [ __ ] in another city you
know what i'm saying that's exactly what
they be doing like they need to make
this [ __ ] to work if these [ __ ] do
that [ __ ] and they get counting they
lies them whole need to be prosecuted
they need to [ __ ] you can't tell me a
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] can uh
watch out who you [ __ ] with and and and
be less trying to [ __ ] with your owlet
yeah i i i agree with all of you i feel
like if you falsely accuse somebody of
something
if you're if you find out that you are
being lied you need to be charged with
the same amount of jail time as if as
for the crime you're accusing that other
person stop a lot of this broke [ __ ]
hustle [ __ ] that they doing that'll stop
a lot of false allegations people want
to do this [ __ ] just get the money
they'll stop a lot of that [ __ ] make the
hoes pay for their consequence that's a
yeah i agree man i agree 100